hello everyone I hope we're all having a
great Saturday and I kinda overdid it
yesterday I uploaded four videos but
that's because I'm not gonna be home
today to do any videos I decided to do a
different type of video this one I'm
gonna be trying out to do magnus carlsen
play up the play magnus up and well this
all happening while I'm pretending I'm
not gonna be doing any more alpha0
videos
so basically I've I downloaded this app
as soon as it was released that was
mostly interested in the video content I
saw that there will be some full
high-definition videos there but I never
actually tried playing against the app
so the way I thought this could go I'm
just gonna start from age 5 that's the
lowest level and work my way up I'm
probably not gonna get very far
since my style of play is really all
about tricking the opponent and I don't
think this will work against an engine
but I will give it my best and let's see
how it goes so let's start a new game
yes let's go all the way to age 5 says
when I turned 5 my father tried to get
me interested in chess but I instead
spent my time memorizing the population
flag and capital of all countries in the
world can you beat me while I'm busy
reading geography books ok let's let's
give it a shot
ok it's loading and we have the white
pieces and at first when I tried this
app on my phone I didn't really I didn't
really really like the design of the
pieces but ok I guess you can kind of
get used to it but I prefer the normal
design I don't mind the metallic color
though ok let's go Bishop d3 just Castle
and go c3 Bishop e3 and ok King f7 it's
a very interesting
let's go b4 I don't think he actually
has any threads there so I'm just gonna
grab the piece I think this is like
totally beginners level so I'm not gonna
really think about moves that much
that's just wandering a queen okay let's
capture here and it's a very funny way
of playing okay let's get here
and threaten checkmate
let's go here
okay so that's h5 let's let's let's go
on okay we'll get some stars here and
five of five or some thunder thingies
let's play choose age let's I'm gonna
skip the five and a half I'm gonna go to
six says I still didn't have much of an
interest in chess although I did play
occasionally at the time I was a big fan
of the pirate captain sabertooth in
Norwegian he was called the captain
Sybil town okay and liked dressing up as
him
are you ready to challenge me as a dream
of golden treasure kay let's try the app
at age six
efore so let's see what's the what's the
improvement of one year okay let's go
the Sicilian I was just gonna I'd see
three probably now captures no okay
capture capture let's just develop
probably push f4 so I always hated
playing against the engine because I
never knew if it was a brilliant move
her if it was a terrible move I don't
know let's go
I was just open up bf file okay not
interested in this what's capture here
capture and capture here trying pick up
the Queen if he doesn't react okay not
gonna capture it right away I guess I
can still improve
okay I do have to capture it now let's
check here go Queen f3 capture and can
you see oh yeah you can see he can see
mate capture just go like this and queen
b7 checkmate okay that's that was h6 so
let's let's continue okay
congratulations you're you're worth the
player let's go to h7 I'm gonna skip six
and a half
my interest in chess perked as I watched
my dad and older sister play there to
challenge a child with a healthy case of
sibling rivalry
okay let's try we get the black pieces
ledger is gonna go d 4 d 4 D 5 and let's
see 5 how does he play against this okay
let's check here all right let's go f6
never seen that move it's a free piece
I'm gonna take it okay let's go
p7 so I guess we're winning now let's
capture here and castle no okay so
another piece let's castle now let's
capture this guy and develop the bishop
probably get our ropes to the open files
let's threaten checkmate okay this is
what check I don't want to capture
you'll just be able to exchange Queens
Oh like that okay let's just check here
now let's take first capture once
the capture once and what now I guess we
go back okay let's check him now Queen
here I'm just gonna grab a pond Queen
captures pawn let's get the rook into
the game okay that's just weird
let's capture capture and capture this
guy let's go here kind of restrict the
Kings movement so threaten checkmate
okay he's not interested in defending it
so let's go win c1 Queen Queen c2 Queen
a to checkmate okay so that was a h7
let's see if we can improve
okay got 25 thunder thing is
congratulations
okay let's skip seven-and-a-half okay
here it is I first beat my sister at the
age of eight I started to spend hours in
front of the chessboard and read my
father's chest book everything from find
the plan by bent Larsen to complete to
the complete dragon better refresh your
reading list before you challenge me at
eight okay let's try it out okay again
with the black pieces and let's go to
standard g5 see what see what he plays
was it go for some nice to f6 let's try
this capture capture let's go Bishop c5
let's go B five castles okay okay very
nice
it's actually not bad it's actually
better here so okay
h8 is already a serious opponent capture
queen e7 capture oh that kind of drops
the rook I was that wasn't very smart
but okay let's do it
he's not gonna capture it yeah I thought
I thought he might not
let's go like this first yeah he's gonna
give up the Queen but I don't think it
works now I don't think it works let's
just get our pieces to optimal squares
create some breathing room for the King
first to get our King to safety and I
guess now just exchange one Bishop and
that's it so here okay hopefully I don't
blunder any bones so I just captured
this guy okay he can push here so it's
not really the best idea
not really the best idea let's just huh
okay this is already he's tricking me
can't really go for those spawns I'm
just gonna attack the rook and the pawn
at the same time okay let's grab this
one now I think I have too much material
let's grab this one all right and I
guess just push pull the a point should
be should be completely winning
let's go here
okay let's get our queen out capture
capture and I guess sh5 is an order here
simply let's see if you place it okay
let's go here now capture and okay I
don't feel like thinking too much let's
just go into two points up an endgame
and I don't think there's anything you
can do okay let's just start pushing
push push
let's push okay let's go for this pawn
let's push here push further I know it
seems that it it isn't programmed to
resign
yeah probably all the way there okay
Queen don't want to stalemate him that
would be that would be terrible
so I just sacrifice a pawn here let's go
here allow him to push a pawn and okay
[Music]
okay so that's a Jade again we're gonna
get some stars and I have to go next
okay again I get three stars and 35 35
Thunder points I don't know how these
thunder points are distributed obviously
by how many mistakes you make or
something so let's go again
we have aged nine back in 1999 during a
game of blitz chess I beat my dad for
the first time in between learning this
ski jump at the sky jump or ski jump
probably and spending time with friends
I also began training performer
Norwegian junior champion Torbjorn ring
dull hands
I'm only nine don't be afraid okay let's
let's try and get past nine okay let's
go again since since age eight was a
pretty strong in refuting my Russian
gambit I'm not gonna go for such such
things again stage nine okay let's go go
should be seven probably five now yeah I
have to be really careful here let's go
d4 here d5 captures captures that cannot
okay he's not interested in capturing it
so let's just play King f8 let's develop
here he's really really annoying
let's go Knight b6 try and get our
Bishop into the game Bishop II and I
can't really do that I have to go Bishop
g4 let's exchange pieces just to get
some activity here let's go here like
this capture capture no really think
that's good okay it's really weird
capture here okay this is really weird
let's capture here I mean what am I
missing here oh that's my king
oh I thought I thought I cancelled oh
that's a shame
so down a piece now and what can I do
here not much actually can I threaten
something not really let's just go here
trying to stop the King from entering
the game and I can't really I can't
really stop his rook or anything he's
probably gonna go for my b7 pawn no
capture here yes of course that's that's
what I was expecting
okay
[Music]
can I can I make this work okay does
this win it sure seems so but we'll see
right there captures night here captures
captures check okay I guess that you
have to go here
attack the rook oh he does have that oh
that's unfortunate captures
[Music]
let's just go for this this guy here
it's capture okay he's preparing to
checkmate me
do I have a way out of this I don't
think I do
oh of course he can't but hmm this is
this is one nice checkmate rook here can
I stop this nope I don't think I can
okay so I'll allow him to check made me
and try against aged nine again okay
choose aged aged nine okay let's go for
a rematch
let's go Knight f6
c5 let's go for some Czech Benoni see
how the app deals with this
let's go like this probably f5 school
night here let's let's get rid of that
Queen but not like that okay
let's play Knight f6 capture capture
capture here and let's push like this
let's see what do we have here let's go
right here try and infiltrate with 93 ok
and what now what do I do now
he's gonna go before something or 9f2
I guess I guess I guess
still have to defend this pawn here so I
guess I'll just play Ruby 8 for now you
didn't want to capture okay let's just
capture the bishop go here and okay
let's go h5 and capture this guy here
captures let's capture here okay just
gonna capture my pawn now but I don't
think it really matters
we'll see he doesn't have any checks or
anything he can push d6 alright let's go
rook f8 not allowing rocky f1 okay he
does have that but but but how do we
make progress
we go here you'll probably push the pawn
again so I think I'll just go back okay
let's push here check check okay I don't
think this works although it might check
here okay I don't have any checks there
but I can capture this pawn Queen
captures and I capture night with check
I guess this works okay and now I just
have to be careful not to blunder this
he doesn't have any checks with the
knight the Queen can't check the rook
will come to g1 probably so I guess the
optimal move is
Queen here with ideas of Queen h6 okay
let's still can't get the bishop into
the game that's a shame
let's still go if I go here then I have
checked okay let's try this let's try it
like this
now now Queen e6 is possible but
shouldn't be too much trouble
[Music]
I'd rather just get rid of the night
somehow
Queeny six okay let's just see what he
does okay I guess I was expecting that
oh yeah of course
wait wait - blunder it away okay I'm
just gonna since I do have a repeat move
so what do I do here this is very very
interesting of all the moves I chose
Bishop g5 that's that's epic
I don't really see a way to make
progress here how about how about Bishop
h4 does this work okay check now here
rook h1 probably Oh Queen captures okay
and he wants to go for the endgame I
guess that's fair rook check no so I'm
free to grab the bone
not really
let's go for this guy and now for the
night okay let's go for the pawn
although a6 was probably a better move
yeah that's that's not really gonna work
but I can check and then I guess maybe
maybe this could work
he does have Czech and candle if I
defend he captures captures he can push
and is my king close enough I get here I
think it is it's not close enough to win
but it could be close enough we'll see
okay I'm definitely better now
let's go here I don't mind the checks
let's go here I don't think he can move
okay yeah that was a that was a bad idea
but I can't push the pawn now although
exchanging is also great yeah
okay I can even push now let's just
capture it and let's get rid of those
pawns but no this is actually not good
for me oh man he pushes totally totally
forgot about this yeah
and now this this is a passer oh I hate
engines even weak engines nothing this
is this is a week at age nine but it
probably is okay I'm not I'm resigning
this so okay this is the first time I
tried out the app I will try to get
better at it since it's very different
to play engines I never really played
engines got to age eight so what do you
think did you try out the app and to
what age did you get so yeah that's a
bit of a different video just enjoying a
Saturday morning and like I said I'm not
gonna be home today I might get back in
time to do a video on the London chest
classic round seven thank you all for
watching I would like to thank prodromos
Matsoukas and Valentina Lanza for
contribution to my channel think a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here I think
all for watching and I will see you soon